we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P
eople are calling in because of the
story I told on the bonus show about my
flight back from San Francisco
and people are criticizing me even
though I was the victim
of Pricks on my flight take a listen
Davis Alan from Jersey and I was
listening to the bonus show yesterday
and you were telling another story of
your airline travel yeah and all these
airline travel stores you tell are
exactly the same thing I've told like
two stories you're the only one that
knows the procedure to get to your seat
you're the only one that knows the right
time to put the window shade up the
right time to put the windows shade down
the proper procedure to get your bag in
the overhead bin you're the only one
that knows how to do the roller bag and
the personal item everybody else is
doing it wrong David you're the only one
or perhaps David
in these situations in these situations
you should step back and say am I the
only one that knows how to put the bags
in the overhead bin am I the only one or
perhaps everybody else is doing it the
right way and you're doing it the wrong
way David I'm the problem clearly think
about this David because it can't be
that everybody else is always wrong and
doing it the wrong way all right listen
dude I told one story in 2021 on a
Lufthansa flight from Frankfurt to JFK
in which I explained that there was a
particular guy okay this was a 747 out
of 400 people there was one guy who
yelled at me because I used an overhead
bin okay all the other 399 people on the
flight did the right thing it's not
everybody's doing it wrong and I'm doing
it right I then have had 10 flights
since then where nobody's done anything
wrong and last week on my flight back
from San Francisco
one guy jumped ahead of me pushed his
way past me to cram his bag into the
obvious spot where I was about to lift
my bag
there were 180 people on that flight 179
of them including my daughter all
behaved perfectly
it's not everybody's doing everything
wrong get out of here give me a break
dude okay we've got a great bonus show
for you today
the Supreme Court is putting some first
amendment limits on laws that ban online
threats why what are those limits we're
going to discuss it there is a Delaware
City that is going to give corporations
the right to vote in elections what yes
and lastly a Republican senator is
challenging a union leader to a mixed
martial arts fight at least it's for
charity all of it we are going to talk
about on the bonus show a David Pac-Man
membership costs six bucks a month true
but with a discount code it's only two
you can use the discount code indicted
again and we will have such a great
bonus show for you today we will see you
then otherwise I will be back here
tomorrow if I have anything to say about
it